sounds like work
no tell them i'm in my chair yes he's
just walked in
this is unexpected i can't believe i'm
actually having lunch with
spines i'm just a salesman exactly
you're civilians the kgb won't be
watching it would be a real service to
great britain
what would you want me to do
i'm here to open a door to the
top manufacturers in the west
[Music]
will i be putting myself in danger if
this mission was the least bit dangerous
you really are the last man we'd send
make sure you wear it while you're in
moscow
what does this do shoot poison dart
everyone you meet assume their kgb
every russian is an eye of the state
it'll just be a courier just a career
for russian seat
from now on you will be selling one
thing
the idea that you are an ordinary
businessman and
nothing more than an ordinary
businessman
[Music]
the weapons of war must be abolished
before they apologize
i'm asking you to stop going to moscow i
am asking you as your wife
i didn't want you to be involved
what if i get caught then execute be
correct
[Music]
we can't get him out if things were the
other way around and kofka would abandon
you he would never
leave me to die and i'm not leaving him
i'm volunteering to bring back the best
source of service intelligence you've
got at a time where russia and america
are on the brink of nuclear war
maybe we're only two people
but this is how things change
[Music]
you